you have another link to this show which
is amazing your mother was a special ed
teacher is that correct yes ps31 in
Jersey City and when you were a child
you would go visit your mother at work
yes a lot and and who was her student uh
Lester Lester okay you're talking about
Beetlejuice yes so you knew Beetlejuice
when you were growing up all growing up
and you call him Lester because he was
part of almost like part of your family
uh listen I I I do want to say um you
guys have done a lot I I personally feel
a lot of great things for Lester he I
mean is doing things and seeing places
and uh making money World traveler but
but Lester was I'm not kidding you all
joking aside my mother's assistant at
school he was such a good student wow
and so he was almost like her teacher's
pet you know right and he would run
messages for her and get her supplies
and my mother
um and my brother and I have a really
soft spot for Lester and every time we
hear him on the show I'm I'm really
happy for him so it was probably
shocking to you when you started to hear
Lester on our show or see him on TV with
us it was exciting you know it's like
seeing a friend on a long television
show
did you recognize him immediately on our
show do you think well maybe it's
someone else we uh we had knew it was
Lester so excited he's the pride of ps31